a comedy documentary is a very rare
thing geetha you'd already made a
documentary called Project Kashmir which
is a war documentary and Janet you've
worked on some serious and substantive
feature films working at HBO so how do
you make the transition to a comedy
documentary as difficult as it might be
I I see life as okay every film every
story in my opinion if it's about life
than life is about love and is about
pain so it wasn't difficult at all
because I you know I'm filmmakers I look
up to her like Sydney [ __ ] you know
who doesn't everything anything Geller
who's done everything like life life is
hard and life is hilarious right so
during the war documentary I was in fact
you know it's seven years I was in this
war zone and the one thing that I
noticed that everybody wanted and
everyone talked about was being in love
falling in love staying alive that's all
they wanted so coming out of that story
it was very natural to want to go and
explore love I don't know I mean our
family's very funny it is you know it's
just another story how about you Janet
well also this is a very it's a very it
can be very painful for families when
there is discord over these cultural
issues and when gutten revi started
interviewing you know they found some
stories that were just you know people
that would never speak to each other
again I've run into it among friends of
mine families and they just said we're
not gonna do that
we want to this is gonna be we're gonna
we're gonna make this happy because
that's what we believe and we believe
that if people can laugh and deal with
serious issues then we can all learn
something and enjoy it and that's what
we want to do so it was a it was a
conscious choice not to go there what
point did you come into the process
guten Ravi headshot the initial family
vacation footage in India and had
started to look at it and put it
together they had gotten initial funding
from itvs and they realized that they
there were going to be gaps in the story
because they just didn't want
- when these big important family
moments came along they didn't want to
be sitting there with the camera that
was something that family came first
they didn't want to do it and they had
seen American Splendor which was a film
that I had worked on and they loved the
structure of it
it was narrative also a documentary
also there was animation and comic book
footage and you know even more of a
turned around because the comic book was
about life and you know the biography of
the life and they wanted to do something
like that and I they had a lot of great
ideas about how to do it and I thought
great you know let's let's give this a
try
the first idea was that they wanted to
put the movie together with it would be
like a talk show in rebus mind in his
imagination where he could have he could
talk to any loved experts that he wanted
university professor loved experts or
auntie's and uncles Deepak Chopra and he
would find out the answers like what is
love how do you get it that sort of
thing and they said to me Janet you know
all we want you to do is just put
together this shoot we want to you know
reviel interview these people put it in
front of a white psyche a big white
background so it you know it's sort of
reveries imagination and then we're
gonna be editing for six months we'll be
done with it he just said project
Kashmir took me seven years and I we
didn't have to do that it could have
been one year six months and we'll be
done how long ago is that that was
almost six years ago so it's didn't take
sure that DubLi way she got duped
we ended I'm not going with the white
psyche we ended up trying four or five
things through the years and it's one of
the reasons it took so long yeah because
you started with essentially a vacation
in a new video camera and at what point
did the light bulb come on for both of
you to say we think this is a film and
then what were the stages of reaching
what kind of film it became so I you
know I think the seed of it was probably
I was I'm seeing this 500 person
Indian lawyers convention here in LA and
I was just kind of riffing on how that
day my mom had sent over these
matrimonial resumes Patel girls and I
was supposed to just cold call them up
and say hey I'm Ravi some person neither
of us know thinks we'd be great together
for life do you want to Skype talk about
how awkward it is and how everyone in
that room kind of knew what I was
talking about and I was killing in a way
that I had never killed before because
there was something behind the laughter
that you could feel in the room at that
so it was like cathartic when you told
me about it yeah yeah and and I even
stopped for a moment I go wait a second
how many of you in this room are single
and everyone except for the organizers
basically raised their hand these are
lawyers right these are Indian lawyers
and they're jain which is like a sect of
it's like hindu adjacent religion and I
was oh yeah that's why that's why you're
here actually there's not like a legal
reason to ever get another Jain lawyer
on the horn do you know how to lock up a
case like it's yet another kind of
institutional front that has evolved
from this kind of cultural requirement
to marry within and afterwards
everyone's coming up to me and they're
like I'm so glad you talked about that
like I hope you do a comedy tour on this
or write a book which I don't have the
work ethic for so that didn't happen and
then you know I was in my mind though
that this was something because people
are sharing their stories in their
hilarious and their their tragic even we
heard stories of suicide and your own
cousin who ran away from home because of
you know her parents wanting to arrange
her marriage and so we knew that this
was an important subject but we also
knew that in order to address it we
wanted to address it in a way well I'm
probably skipping ahead huh no you're
not no no no I mean I think I think well
I look what happened was just like in
the movie we just finished broken up
with Audrey I was really wrestling with
feeling kind of spineless about you know
not ever telling mom and dad about her
and Here I am on this 18-hour flight to
India where mom and dad only have one
thing on their mind and they are
obviously sharing it because everyone in
my family
doesn't stop talking and Gita's got this
new camera which she never learned how
to use and and you know we're having
these conversations and all of this is
like all of the anxiety suffering was
just so funny I was taking a break I had
just finished this war film and I was
broke I had sold my car to finish it I
mean it was a Corolla so no it wasn't a
bunch of money
and so I you know got her another two
weeks down the road how to use a camera
and I'm when I like take a break and you
know just film the family trip and just
relax finally you know
Ravi's babbling on about this convention
you had gone to and how he's the key
that we have to do something we have to
we have to document this I was like yeah
you do it I'll help you you know I had
worked with PBS so I was like look I'll
help you do it but I'm not doing it I
need a piano I need a boyfriend like I
need something else Facebook but he's
like going through this and I just
couldn't help but film it I mean it was
just hilarious I remember telling me I
didn't know you'd had a girlfriend
no they know I did it all it's never
dated before and they've never dated
before no but I remember telling I'm
never telling dads giving dating advice
like he doesn't know what he's doing you
know when you talk to the guard or
anything you know in that scene you
can't really hear him where he's giving
me that pep speech and he like slaps me
like like with the back of his hand what
he says and you couldn't hear it he goes
come on go to my son
so how when it came time to pitch this
how did you pitch it so people didn't
see it as an ethnic film but a family
film well to be honest we didn't know it
was a film about family when we started
I mean when we started making this I
mean the working title this film was one
in a billion for you know up until eight
but now let's go for in a billion for
debilities the name of our production
company cuz we thought it was cute it
went well with the title now it's just
weird but you know at the time we
thought it was gonna be we thought were
gonna make this like Michael Moore
Morgan Spurlock thing we're all more of
a journalist like academic what's
happening in the country right now
yeah we're interviewing all these
different people and
and you know what happened was it came
back and we realized there's something
really interesting about these intimate
conversations that we were having and
also kind of the growing irony that this
person behind the camera was actually
hiding behind the camera and going
through things even worse and so once we
kind of fell in love with that dynamic
you know we started to explore you know
obviously it's convenient like she's my
sister we lived together by the way we
also don't live together anymore so
there is a happy ending that keeps going
there